one side seems open to a marathon the
other a sprint after the slow creep of
wrangling over rules the prosecution had
the floor trying to lay out the stakes
Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment if not remedied by his
conviction in the Senate and removal
from office president Trump's abuse of
his office and obstruction of Congress
will permanently alter the balance of
power among the branches of government
in truth there was nothing new in what
he said a compromise over who can
testify could change that but it's
sounding unlikely are you open to in
principle a witness exchange so that
Republicans can for instance call on
hunter Biden this isn't like some
fantasy football trade as I said
yesterday this isn't we'll offer you
this if you give us that will offer you
a witness that is irrelevant and
immaterial who has no relevant testimony
but a witness that will allow us to
smear a presidential candidate if you
want to get a legitimate witness that's
not a trade trials aren't trades for
witnesses there are they clear
strategies evolving in private the
Republican leadership is reportedly
trying to persuade moderates in the
party not to support new witnesses like
john bolton from testifying but even if
they did the president could well exert
executive privilege to stop that from
happening in davos the president seemed
to hint at exactly that
the problem with john is that it's a
national security problem you know you
can't have somebody who's at national
security and if you think about it John
he knows some of my thoughts he knows
what I think about leaders what happens
if he reveals what I think about a
certain leader and it's not very
positive and that I have to deal on
behalf of the countries back in
Washington a deeply split Senate turned
up the heat they're on a crusade to
destroy this man and they don't care
what they destroy in the process
of trying to destroy Donald Trump I do
care I do not know how you have a trial
without witnesses we are getting all of
the evidence and it seems to me that my
Republican colleagues are more
interested in protecting the president
and having a free and open trial the
polls will tell you half of this country
want the president removed from office
but this is about politicians who insist
they are led by the public
cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington